A LOT HAS CHANGED IN TWO WEEKS.
>> Juan: LET'S FIND OUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW WITH
LAWMAKERS AND THESE BILLS TO
REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT.
JAY CONGRESSIONAL CORRESPONDENT
MIKE EMANUEL IS ON CAPITOL HILL
TONIGHT.
>> ONCE THERE IS AGREEMENT,
THINGS MOVE VERY QUICKLY ON
CAPITOL HILL.
THIS BILL HAS CLEARED THE SENATE
AND SHOULD PASS THE HOUSE VERY
SOON AND BE SENT UP TO THE
PRESIDENT TO SIGN TO GET
FURLOUGH DEFENSE BACK TO WORK.
>> I'M GRATEFUL -- --
>> TOP DEMOCRATS WERE HOLDING A
LINE ON THE PARTIAL SHUTDOWN
WITH GOVERNMENT REOPENING IN A
HURRY THE HOPE IS THE STATE OF
THE UNION ADDRESS WILL BE
RESCHEDULED SOON.
>> IT IS NOT PLAN NOW.
>> THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER'S
WARNING DEMOCRATS MUST BE
SERIOUS OR ELSE.
>> THE ONLY WAY FEDERAL WORKERS
ARE GOING TO HAVE STABILITY AND
CERTAINTY BEYOND THE NEXT THREE
WEEKS, THE ONLY WAY OUR BORDER
IS GOING TO HAVE REAL SECURITY
IS IF DEMOCRATS WILL STOP
PLAYING PARTISAN GAMES AND GET
SERIOUS ABOUT NEGOTIATING WITH
THE PRESIDENT ON A LONG-TERM
COMPROMISE.
>> SUPPORTERS OF THE PRESIDENT
ARE PRAISING HIM FOR BEING THE
GROWN UP THE ROOM.
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE TODAY
IS THE PRESIDENT PUT THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC FIRST.
THE PRESIDENT SAID LET'S PAY THE
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES AND LET'S GET
INTO A MEETING ROOM BECAUSE WE
TRIED TO MEET WITH THE SPEAKER
AND CHUCK SCHUMER AND THEY WILL
NOT NEGOTIATE.
>> NORTH CAROLINA REPUBLICAN
MARK MEADOWS IS SAYING IF
NEGOTIATIONS DON'T RESULT IN A
SOLUTION, EXECUTIVE ACTION IS
UNDER CONSIDERATION.
THE DEMOCRATIC CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOMELAND SECURITY COMMITTEE SAYS
DEMOCRATS REMAIN COMMITTED TO
EFFECTIVE BORDER SECURITY BUT
WILL ONLY ALLOW TAXPAYER MONEY
TO BE SPENT ON SECURITY MEASURES
THAT WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
LAWMAKERS WERE CLEARLY FEELING
THE PRESSURE HEARING ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF THE PARTIAL SHUTDOWN
FOR CONSTITUENTS AND SEEKING A
WAY OUT.
>> THE REAL RAMIFICATIONS OF THE
SHUTDOWN ARE STARTING TO BE
SEEN, IT'S NOT AN AGGREGATING
EFFECT -- I THINK YOU'LL SEE A
CASCADING EFFECT.
>> A HOMELAND SECURITY
SPOKESWOMAN SAID BACKPAY SHOULD